COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I show a fishing
friend all the tools
he'll need to catch a
big performance problem.
Will this be the
one that got away?
Stay tuned to find out.
So my friend Carter
has built a new website
called Bait & Stitch which helps
fishing enthusiasts connect
with designers to
make custom apparel.
After a few weeks in beta,
Carter asked for some help.
He was noticing that
his request latency
got significantly slower under
heavy load due to the fact
that new instances took
longer times to start.
Now, typically when I
hear feedback like this
it means one thing--
cold boot performance.
See, when a new
app engine instance
is spun up for
the first time, it
has to execute a bunch
of work that only
occurs during initial boot--
things like starting
the debugger,
initializing global
variables, or populating
some memcached data.
Performance becomes a concern
here because instances
that are typically created
in response to a request that
comes in.
So if an instance is
booting up, the total time
to respond to that
request is a function
of the normal work that needed
to be done for that response,
as well as any startup work
that has to be done as well.
Now, to be very,
very, very clear here,
cold boot performance
isn't normally a problem.
App Engine startup
time is really fast.
I mean take a look at this.
I charted the cold boot time for
basic Hello World Application
across various instant types.
250 milliseconds is actually
pretty fast for an F2 instance
to boot up.
I mean, that's
technically faster
than fetching a JavaScript
file for most CDNs on a 4G
connection.
Which means GAE by itself
is really good at responding
to instance creation time.
However, the users
of Bait & Stitch
were noticing performance issues
because of cold boot time,
which meant that it
was time for Carter
and I to sit down and
dig in and figure out
what was going wrong.
And our first stop was take
a look at the logging data.
See, App Engine does
a really good job
of logging information about
each request that it receives,
most important of which is how
long it took for the request
to be handled by the service.
Now, logged items which
correspond to system events
are often logged in blue.
Startup time is
one of those items,
so we can click on the log
entry to get more data.
Startup requests will
typically have a header value
of loading requests set to one.
Furthermore, these
log entries are
flagged with some
extra information
that tells you about the
instance being spun up,
and how it will be a little bit
slower than a typical request.
Now, looking at the logs
we can see that there's
a group of really fast requests
at the bottom of the set, which
confirms exactly what we're
expecting-- the loading request
is actually pretty slow.
What we didn't
expect, however, is
the batch of calls
in the middle which
follow the loading request.
Those are just as slow, but
sadly, at this point logging
won't give us any
more information.
So it's time to switch
over to something
a little more powerful.
And one of the nice things
about App Engine being
a platform as a
service is that it's
got a bunch of nifty other tools
built into it that you don't
have to go generate yourself.
One of the more powerful
ones is Stackdriver tracing.
See, in addition
to being logged,
each request that comes
through App Engine standard
gets its RPC call information
tracked and listed
in Stackdriver.
To find loading requests we
need to dig around a bit.
They typically aren't
listed directly,
but they have a higher response
time than normal requests
that come through.
To confirm this, you
can select a trace.
If the debuglet started command
is in the trace details,
then it's what
you're looking for.
This block only executes when a
new instance has been spawned.
So it's a clear sign that
this was a request that
caused a cold boot to occur.
Now, as mentioned, any RPC
calls that your app makes
will be logged here.
And we can see that this app
is touching Memcache, doing
a fetch, and pushing some
stuff to task queues.
None of those really look
like a performance problem
at this point.
But what's really
interesting here
is that there's about
900 milliseconds
before the socket was created--
to allow a connection
to the instance.
This is a rough indicator
of the startup time taken.
So App Engine's boot
time isn't the problem,
and none of our RPC
requests are the problem,
but Bait & Stitch's loading
time is still about 1.2 seconds.
Hmm.
To get more insight we need
to profile more of our code.
See, tracing does a
great job of keeping
a tab of what RPC
function calls take,
but it doesn't track
all custom code that
occurs between those calls.
To do that, we need to leverage
the Stackdriver trace API
that allows us to insert custom
tracing data into our requests.
Carter and I were able to write
a small utility class which
tracked the start and end
time of various code segments,
and would turn those results
into a JSON string on demand.
Adding a little
entry/exit setup,
and we quickly had an API to log
how long a block of code takes.
Passing that data off
to the Stackdriver API
allowed us to insert custom
tracing data for blocks of code
that weren't previously
being logged.
Pretty neat, huh.
Now with the custom
tracing setup,
we now had a very
clear picture of what
was going wrong in the Bait &
Stitch application's cold boot
time.
And it wasn't pretty.
But to figure out
that problem we
needed to dig in
a little deeper,
which is a subject
for a different video.
If you want to learn more
about tracking down performance
problems, make sure you check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas videos.
And don't forget, when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]